The entertainment world lost one of its most
iconic performers on Sunday, January 9.
TMZ reported that Bob Saget was found deceased
in his Ritz-Carlton hotel room in Orlando,
Florida at approximately 4 p.m. ET.
The Orange County Sheriff's Office tweeted
out more details a few hours later, elaborating
that "detectives found no signs of foul play
or drug use in this case."
As of the making of this video, it is still
unclear what the exact cause of death is,
and it may take time before that information
is made public.
In a statement issued after the announcement
of Saget's passing, his family said,
"We are devastated to confirm that our beloved
Bob passed away today ... He was everything
to us and we want you to know how much he
loved his fans, performing live and bringing
people from all walks of life together with
laughter ... Though we ask for privacy at
this time, we invite you to join us in remembering
the love and laughter that Bob brought to
the world."
As seen on both his Twitter and Instagram
accounts, the actor and stand-up comedian
shared a photo from the stage of the venue
where he most recently performed — less
than 24 hours before his passing.
In his post, where he is seen smiling, he
wrote,
"I had no idea I did a two hour set tonight.
I’m back in comedy like I was when I was
26.
I guess I’m finding my new voice and loving
every moment of it."
Bob Saget led a very interesting career which
spanned more than 40 years.
Of course, his most well-known role is playing
the widowed father of three, Danny Tanner,
on the popular late '80s and '90s sitcom "Full
House."
The show ran for eight years, and he later
reprised the same role when the "Fuller House"
reboot launched on Netflix in 2016.
Saget's career in television was, of course,
more prolific than his role on the hit ABC
sitcom.
The "Full House" alum also hosted the popular
series "America's Funniest Home Videos," beginning
in 1989 and ending in 1997.
On the heels of these two gigs, Saget returned
to television dad territory with The WB sitcom
"Raising Dad," co-starring Brie Larson and
Kat Dennings.
Additionally, Saget can be heard as the Narrator
of the series "How I Met Your Mother," where
he takes on the role of the older version
of Ted Moseby, played in flashbacks on the
show by Josh Radnor.
"Kids, I'm going to tell you an incredible
story.
The story of how I met your mother."
In contrast to his more wholesome, family-friendly
television work, Saget was also well-known
for his delightfully vulgar and boundary-pushing
stand-up comedy.
Audiences got a taste of this on-screen thanks
to Saget's voice role in 2006's "Farce of
the Penguins," and an appearance in the documentary
"The Aristocrats," a film about the most infamous
dirty joke in the standup comedy world.
Despite his success on TV, taking to the stage
to perform standup appeared to be something
that never got old for Saget.
"I am dirty.
Apparently I am dirty."
If you've ever seen one of Bob Saget's taped
stand-up specials or had the pleasure of seeing
him perform live, then you likely know that
his stand-up comedy was often a departure
from the more family-oriented TV shows that
he became well-known for.
Saget was still touring as a stand-up at the
time of his death and based on interviews
he gave in his final years, it sounds as though
he took great pleasure in being able to make
people laugh.
In 2017, Saget spoke to The Tennessean in
the midst of a four-month standup tour.
He told the publication,
"It's like, 'How can I be 60 and still love
this so much?'"
It seems that love only grew stronger.
When asked by Alabama.com about how the COVID-19
pandemic had affected his standup career,
Saget discussed pivoting to podcasts.
However, he also shared that being away from
live audiences only made his heart grow fonder.
The comedian revealed,
"But stand-up, once I was able to get back
to it, it really took me only one show to
really get into it and realize how much I
loved it.
More than I have since, you know, 1995."
Saget's love of entertaining was clearly reflected
in the number of people who turned to his
humor for comfort.
Whether you knew him best for his fatherly
persona on TV or his edgier standup, Saget
will be sorely missed.
His contributions to the entertainment world
will be remembered for years to come.